I'm thrilled to be able to call this man
a friend uh for as long as I have uh
he's one of the all-time great football
players that I was able to cover and get
to meet and he's joining us on behalf of
the new CBD Company Green Eagle uh he is
none other than Hall of Famer Brett
Favre how are you
Brett Rich I'm good and I I pick sha
Shank Redemption is that your choice
that's your choice sha sh what do you
like about sha shank Brent it's hard to
beat everything
um right from start to finish I mean you
were hanging on the edge of your seat so
uh now he's had some great movies but
that I think that that one uh is number
one that's the top five movie for you
know regardless of genre so I I got to
go here then Brett Favre your your top
five movies you're on a you're on a
you're on a desert island you know
you're going to the desert island you
could bring five movies with you and
this is what you're going to watch until
you're rescued what are those those five
movies
Brett uh in no particular order a
longone Survivor um Green Mile sha Shank
Redemption um the judge the judge and uh
it's a tossup between like force Gump
Castaway
um 13 hours to
Benghazi I
mean well so you're h hard to pick five
you're a Hanks guy there's a lot of Tom
Hanks in there Tom Hanks I love Tom
Hanks I love Tom Cruz I love Morgan
Freeman um Richard Gear Kevin cner you
know some of those old movies Primal
Fear uh The Bodyguard you know
uh you know those guys are are are
Classics so you Robert diro alpacino did
you ever meet these guys any have you
met ever met any of these guys because
you just named a bunch of football fans
too
BR no no i' never have I'd love to meet
them I'd love to meet each and every one
of them I I I take that back I did meet
Kevin cner at uh in the locker room
after a giant game and and a funny story
this was in New York we won the game my
dad was in the locker room and uh Kevin
CER for I don't know what he was doing
there but he he came in and said hello
and my was sitting and my dad kind of
just turned and saw him and he's like
holy the
postman the postman and I was like I
didn't know I I had no clue what my dad
I didn't see the movie I had I didn't
know and so I'm like Dad what are you
doing you know of all the movies the
post
man that's
amazing the post classic classic I'm
like that would you shut
up so keev Kevin seemed to get a kick
out of it I'm sure he did so maybe did
is did you reach out to anybody acting
wise to prepare for your role in
Something About Mary Brett or you just
relied on your own instincts for that
one no but I no I wish I would
have uh I tell people all the time I
said you know they I should win an Oscar
for that because they told me to act
stiff and
nervous well you nailed it you nailed it
as Brett fav that was that's an old
time Brett fav here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk a little bit of football
before we get into green Eagle here a
little bit um uh last I think maybe last
we spoke on this show it was right after
Jordan love got drafted and you were
recounting a a conversation that you had
with Aaron roders about that Drafting
and about how it might manifest itself
this year and my gosh uh Aaron has shown
up maybe playing the best football he's
ever played Brett what do you and he
came on here he said that he's at peace
he used the phrase at peace about where
he is in his career I wonder what your
your thoughts are on the the start of
Rogers the Packers prior to visiting Tom
Brady this
week well I I think I I totally agree
with you rich I think he's playing uh
it's hard to to say he's playing his
best football ever uh because he's
played so well for so for so long but
but I really believe he's elevated his
team I I can't say that statistically
he's that much better but I think he's
about as good as you can get but more
importantly he's elevated the guys
rounding uh to you know to close to his
status and they're playing
outstanding you know I I don't want to
say look unbeatable but as close to to
unbeatable it's kind of frightening um
you know because you say if you're a
Packers fan can we get any better you
know there's we almost have nowhere to
go but down now I don't think that they
will I'm just saying that that's that's
kind of where they are right now and you
know I think eron has always done a
great job and I believe that the greats
uh do this as well as anyone find the
motivation when it seems like there's
none out there you know you've done it
all you've seen it all you've
experienced it all uh so what what
drives you and and I think Aon does a
great job finding that motivation
whether it be drafting a Young
quarterback and not drafting a a player
that could help him um you know this
year whatever that may be he's found a
way to channel that into motivation and
and you know play as well as he's ever
played and I know uh again uh that that
that is a motivating factor one would
think uh when I did have him on he said
that he's just been working on himself
this off season and it doesn't seem at
least he's not saying uh that the Jordan
love drafting has sparked this but um it
seems that it might have Brett what do
you think of
that yeah I think it it probably did but
I think maybe not in the way that most
people would assume uh not in a sense
that you know I'm going to be replaced
but more so from you know I was hoping
for a little help offensively I think
that's that's probably more where the
motivation would come in not I can't
believe that they drafted someone to
take my position and I I assume that
most people think that that that would
be why he'd be motivated I mean he's got
nothing to fear um so uh that's that's
certainly not the issue and you uh
visited Tampa or last month on behalf of
NFL the grind the show that that I I
host on epex uh with NFL films and I
appreciate that you were in the TOA B
the Tom Brady face uh on the buccaneer
um and what do you think of Brady um
right now entering this game at three
and two I know you had some comments
about potentially the arens Brady
relationship and aran's public uh
commentary of Tom um do you think that
there's any issues there or where do you
think the state of Brady is entering
this contest right now Brett far
I I think that there's no issue
whatsoever um between Tom and Bruce
um and there wasn't at that point either
um I I just found a little alive that he
would call Tom out I'm not saying it's
right or wrong or you know it's going to
piss Tom off they may have even talked
about it prior
to you know that coming out but I think
and people may look at a different but I
believe that three and two regardless of
the record let me back up regardless of
their record whether it be five and on
three and two whatever I think that
Thomas played exceptionally well
considering he's had no offseason no
pre-season um little to no work to gain
chemistry that's and as you know rich I
mean that's that's huge um you know for
the teams that are are pretty much
you have been together the co the
schemes and things like that have have
been in place you don't really miss out
that much from a preseason standpoint
the only people that usually miss out uh
or have missed out uh with this
craziness would be the rookies and free
agents changing over to a new team or
being drafted or or picked up by a team
that you're totally unfamiliar with and
that's really what Tom is is experienced
as he is
um that helps to a certain extent but
you still have to get familiar with your
your new plays the guys running them how
they run routes uh those guys have to
get used to how your Cadence
uh you know every Cadence is
different throwing Styles what you what
your dos and your don'ts your likes your
dislikes and to be able to do that on
the fly like day one I mean their first
preseason game was open and done against
the ph and you know those guys have to
realize that Tom's going to stay in the
pocket and he's going to all he needs is
a little nudge here or there and what
that nudge is and where that nudge needs
to be is something you got to figure out
and and they're figuring it out so I
think up to this point he's played
exceptionally well where do you stand on
the subject Brett Favre of Drew Brees
the national conversation about his arm
strength and his age and him not uh
having as much command of an offense um
that we're used to seeing even though
he's without his top receiver for the
last month where do you stand on that
subject I well I think it's ridiculous
to be honest with you because Drew's
never had a strong arm um obviously he
hasn't been 40 years old forever but
that you know that that's the first
thing that everyone points to I think 10
years from now the 40y old um excuse
will be used anymore because you'll see
more and more guys playing into you know
their 40s uh but it but it seems to be
the popular excuse to make that you know
a player's in his 40s and and therefore
he shouldn't he shouldn't be able to
play at a high level and that's what
throng with Drew Brees that's what
throng with Tom Brady so on and so forth
I think it's absolutely ridiculous
because neither one of their games
relies on tremendous arm strength or
Mobility um you know I think there's a
lot of factors that go into success
uccess or lack of success and neither of
which um has anything to do with with
arm strength or
age so let's talk about green Eagle
Brett Favre um you are now the official
brand ambassador for those who need to
know about this and what it does for you
it's the new CBD company I give you the
floor
here on this yeah you know if you you
and I would have been talking a year ago
uh just in general said hey you ever
think about getting in the CBD world you
know it's everywhere I see see signs I
see
scores like everyone else I'd have said
absolutely not um you know I never was a
marijuana guy never will
be but you know here I am and and I I
have to admit I was
uh I was wrong in my perception of the
CBD world I'm not that's not to say that
you you know you can't get you know
something you know with THC or
uh I say this jokingly but laced
brownies or you know whatever that's not
my thing never has been uh so when I was
approached by Green eagle and their CEO
uh Joseph I asked him those questions
you know I said hey I spent 75 days in
rehab I actually went to rehab three
times but one time the longest stent was
days and it was uh do in part to to an
addiction of painkillers and you know
the last thing I want to do is be a
spokesman for anything that's
addictive
um and he said absolutely 100% drug free
and um more or less the the for lack of
a better description the hemp plant is a
lot like aloe it has a lot of healing
qualities and and um so I was convinced
that that he was legit and his company
was legit and that uh that they had a
solid product I said I need to try it
and I was training for a half marathon
at the time use the product on on just
general a and pains you know some days I
I felt fine didn't need it other days
maybe a knee was sore or a quad or you
know just typical stuff and I would use
it and was I'll be honest with you I was
really shocked I shouldn't say surprised
it was more shocked that it worked
because I'm kind of a a tough sell on on
things like that and uh and so when it
had worked I said hey I'm all in and
I've given numerous friends and member
samples and I'm not going to tell you
their description of of uh what they
thought of it but it was it was positive
um like this blank blank
works and and I
really kind of my mindset too I couldn't
believe it you know it actually works
you know and so
um I certainly don't want to be a part
of anything that doesn't work and this
works and it's drug free and uh and it's
for everybody green Eagle again it's a a
wellness solution as you mentioned
infused with hemp derived CBD um 100%
free of THC and uh we're looking at you
um you know uh wearing a green Eagle
t-shirt and I think there's another
photograph that we're putting up there
of you holding the green Eagle product
uh if I'm not mistaken is that a blonde
eagle holding up the product right there
did you did you do something during that
was the heart the height of the
quarantine okay my daughter and two her
of her
classmates friends di my hair yep that's
what it looks like so you got
to is it still like that right now Brett
you still you know tinting the front
it's it went back to it's it went back
to its natural color gray okay speak
speaking of which have you seen uh Steve
maruchi showing up on NFL Network he's
just he's like he's like Bob Barker one
day he's uh he's not great next day he's
all great did you notice that BR you
check that out he's he's a cross between
Bob Barker
alucino um you know uh I'm who else I'm
trying to think of but he's got a little
he got a little bit of that C A he he's
got a dairo thing too I agree with you I
agree with you um hey before I let
Before I Let You Go Brett uh with Brady
and and Rogers facing each other this
week we and the media are all going to
be hyping it up and for good reason I
mean they're two tws and they're two
greats they're both going to have busts
in the same room that yours is currently
residing in that beautiful spot in
Canton Ohio do you know obviously
they're not going to be they're going to
be in the field at the same time but
when you are of this stature going into
a game of
uh where somebody else of that stature
is on the other side do you think about
it do you even spend a minute leading up
to the game thinking about it and then
knowing that you have to bring a certain
game coming up do you do
that yeah yes and no I mean I don't
think you dwell on it um you know I
obviously uh I am speaking for those
guys but but I'm really not um because I
don't know exactly what they you know
they're thinking uh nor will I ever but
I know the competive side of that of
that position and in stature and uh you
certainly are aware of it and want to
outduel your opponent but you also know
that you're not playing against that
particular player you're playing against
their defense um you know I I think more
than anything you'd rather get a win
than than better
statistics I hear you was there anybody
that you used to face off that you're
that that it was like that anybody that
came close to it for you
well you know for
me neither one were were in myh division
but uh same conference there was Troy
Eggman and and Steve Young Troy I could
never beat you know again I wasn't
trying to beat him but Troy was as
Flawless as you can get and they ran the
ball like crazy and their defense was
just outstanding now we we
uh and I had a tremendous amount of
respect for Troy and his team and and
and still do um but Steve Young was was
about as Flawless as you could get in a
in a crazy way you know it may be an
unbelievable run it could be but you
know to outd either one of those guys
would have been nothing short of amazing
um but but to to get one of them at
least and I got a tremendous amount of
respect for Steve Young I mean what hell
of a player he was um so I knew more so
against Steve that I had to match him
play for play Troy not so much because
he had so many weapons around him um but
I was fortunate enough to to win a few
against Steve and went over for against
Troy Brett uh always love chatting you
take care of yourself best of your
family you be you be you be well always
good talking with you you got it hey
Brett before I got I got one last one
for you the rookies that you're seeing
out there yeah Herbert burrow anybody
else what you're seeing out of these
guys and the hits that they're taken
anybody impress you particularly out of
the rookies I have to admit I'm not so
as much surprised by burrow um I felt
like he's a little bit older a little
bit seasoned uh last year kind of kind
of I I think prepared him
for the big in fact I think he kind of
took a step down as far as the big big
stage if that makes sense mhm Herbert on
the other hand is kind of an
unknown um but it's quickly coming on
the scene I I'm more surprised by his
play not that he I I thought he would
play bad but I mean he he looks
outstanding burrow is is playing about
what I thought he would play and that's
pretty damn solid I know and he he he
came out he almost I mean you know his
first start was at the last second and
he almost beat momes and your guy Andy
Reed you know
so uh that's pretty big and now and now
Andy's got I think both both those guys
stay healthy they'll they'll be good for
a long time right and then uh you know
Andy's wearing the uh the visor over his
face I think that's the closest he's
ever been to a salad bar don't you think
[Laughter]
BR I I have to admit I agree I agree I
knew you'd like that
line yeah I love it that's that's oh
that's beautiful that's oh Andy will
love that trust me that's as close as
he's ever been to a salad bar you take
care Brett you be
well all right Rich you too right back
at you that's Brett Favre at Brett Favre
on both Twitter and Instagram and he's
here courtesy again of the new CBD
Company Green Eagle he's the official
brand
ambassador look at that look at that
look at the blonde man I noticed that
too I was kind of glad you brought that
up it's kind of Wesley Snipes like right
Demolition Man demolition man little
Demolition Man you like that video of
course you did check out more right
here